vamos a hablar de si realmente somos
robots os hemos cuestionado un poco qué
es lo que pasa con la tecnología hoy en
día y si nosotros somos dependientes de
la tecnología la tecnología será la que
está empezando a ganarnos o
efectivamente sigue siendo una extensión
nuestra para poder hacer de nuestra vida
cada vez algo más sencillo así que el
empoderamiento como herramienta de la
plenitud es nuestra próxima exposición y
en este sentido paula sánchez es un
economista con enfoque liderazgo
directivo y bienestar organizacional a
lo largo de su experiencia profesional
se ha dedicado a apoyar a varias
entidades del sector público en su
fortalecimiento institucional que no les
extrañe que siempre está la casa de
encontrar nuevas oportunidades para
acoplar estos conocimientos en
perfección de su trabajo y esto hace que
en este momento estoy cursando una
maestría en desarrollo organizacional y
liderazgo directivo en la universidad de
barcelona somos o no somos robots qué es
lo que está pasando con la tecnología
nos va a contar pablo
buenos días cómo están compañeros bueno
yo vengo ahora a contarles una historia
hace un par de semanas
estaba intentando acceder a una
aplicación y el sistema me pidió que me
registre y que valide mis datos entonces
inmediatamente ingresé los datos de
rigor nombres completos número de cédula
número de celular un correo electrónico
de contacto etcétera etcétera etcétera y
de pronto
llegó un punto en el cual el sistema
insistía que le demuestre que yo no soy
un robot
entonces pensé
estamos en una época en donde los robots
nos piden que les demostremos que no
somos robots
qué curioso
y comencé un viaje hacia mi pasado
porque realmente sentí un verdadero
dilema existencial en qué parte de mi
vida me convertí en algo confundible con
un robot
y recorría hacia atrás entonces volvía a
mi infancia en donde era una bebé
rosa cante linda y mimada el mundo
estaba a mis pies mis papás me animaban
y me consentían
sólo bastaba con que llorará un poquito
para que me cambiaran el pañal para que
me dieran de comer o para que me
arrollarán si es que era necesario y
claro desde ese desde ésa bebé el mundo
era mío y era un espacio seguro para
vivir y fue creciendo y me convertí en
una niña y desde esa versión de niña
empecé a sentir temores temor a que mi
mami no me quiera temor a que mi papi me
abandoné temor a que la profesora de la
escuela me castigue
temor a que mis compañeros no me acepten
temor a que mis amigos me critiquen en
fin temor a que el sistema me re pruebe
y entonces seguí
caminando por la vida y empecé a
acumular un sistema de creencias un
sistema de creencias muy limitantes en
donde claro tenía miedo a no poder comer
ether me a no ser lo suficiente
a que me olvide a que me atrasé a que me
boten
a que me enferme a que me engañen a que
me abandonen a que me muera
y con ese sistema
cargado en mi mochila seguí caminando
por la vida
y de que a la universidad saqué mi
título profesional y bueno ya era
momento de insertarse en el mercado
laboral y entonces me fui a trabajar
llena de esta mochila de creencias
limitantes en donde por supuesto había
que brillar y había que brillar como esa
punta de ese maravilloso entonces en ese
espacio yo tenía que estar absolutamente
vistosa y empoderada de mis valores
en esa superficie vistosa lo que se
juntaban eran los comportamientos de
todos los que estábamos en ese espacio
de trabajo donde todos teníamos que
brillar entonces claro me di cuenta que
esos comportamientos se repetían que
habían más personas en las oficinas en
mi oficina que actuaban de la misma
manera con unos comportamientos
necesarios para mostrarse brillantes en
ese entorno de trabajo que eran
comportamientos muchas veces
fingidos eran como máscaras como unas
máscaras o unos disfraces que nos
ponemos para andar por la vida siendo lo
que creemos que el sistema quiere que
seamos entonces desde ahí tenemos la
máscara del profesional exitoso la
máscara del profesional irremplazable
del jefe enojado del que siempre cumple
del que siempre da órdenes y nos ponemos
un montón de máscaras en donde somos o
nos convertimos en lo que creemos que el
sistema requiere y desde esos
comportamientos
avanzamos y avanzamos
juntos porque todos estamos como en esta
comedia entonces tanto la comedia en
realidad es una especie de obra de
teatro a ratos
un poco de terror y avanzamos como si
fuésemos unas máquinas perfectas
en donde se nos exige o se nos pide
comportarnos de manera de manera
perfecta tener resultados ser nuestros
resultados y nos olvidamos que por
debajo de ese vistoso icebergs de esa
punta maravillosa
existe toda una estructura profunda una
estructura profunda donde está todo ese
sistema de creencias de miedos de
percepciones de motivaciones de
expectativas de frustraciones de
necesidades que cada uno de nosotros
tiene y entonces como el deseo y la
necesidad en ese espacio es de brillar
entonces realmente nos enfilamos como
una serie de máquinas perfectamente
diseñadas para cumplir esos resultados y
nos convertimos así en una fila de
robots y una esta mañana les traigo una
propuesta diferente un cambio de
paradigma romper esos esquemas qué tal
si trabajamos desde el amor qué tal si
trabajamos desde ese ser de luz que
somos nosotros desde esa posibilidad
infinita de construir esquemas distintos
y eso demanda de nosotros de cada uno de
nosotros un ejercicio de empoderamiento
y que desde el empoderamiento aquí me
permitía hacer una una connotación
idiomática porque la palabra no tiene
traducción exacta en español en el
inglés quiere decir en power meant que
significa de recuperar el poder volver a
tener ese poder interior que se nos
quedó por ahí
significa aumentar la fortaleza
espiritual económica social política de
las personas y comunidades para impulsar
cambios positivos desde ahí y con eso
recuperar esa fortaleza interior que me
devuelve la confianza en mis propias
capacidades porque mi proceso de
empoderamiento es tu proceso de
empoderamiento y es el tuyo y es el tuyo
y es el tuyo porque todos estamos
conectados
porque yo me reflejo en ti porque tú
eres mi espejo porque si yo no tengo
adentro ternura no te puedo ver con amor
porque si yo no tengo adentro alegría no
te puedo ver a leer
y entonces
la propuesta es volvamos a hacer ese ser
humano perfecto que todos somos
ese ser humano que se conecta ese ser
humano que sonríe
ese ser humano empático lleno de
ilusiones
y para ello
les he traído el día de hoy una
propuesta una fácil propuesta como una
receta de cocina en donde
he desarrollado tres tips
el primero
el poder de ti
recupera ese valor esa luz interior que
todos tenemos
y desde esa luz desde ese yo verdadero
cuidemos cuidemos nos cuidemos de
nuestra salud cuidemos de nuestras
emociones cuidemos de nuestra mente
cuidemos nuestros pensamientos cuidemos
nuestras palabras cuidemos nuestras
reacciones
y sobre todo cuidemos nuestros
pensamientos sabían ustedes que
científicamente está comprobado que el
cerebro humano produce alrededor de 60
mil pensamientos por día y de esa
cantidad adivinen cuántos se hacen
realidad alguien de ustedes sabe
apenas el 5% quiere decir que el
restante 95 son inventos de nuestra
mente son cosas que nos pasamos pensando
nos tomaron un montón de energía y nunca
se van a cumplir y son producto de
miedos de situaciones repetitivas de
temores que tuvimos
y que están en nuestra mente entonces
recuperemos ese poder
seamos de salud brillamos abriremos como
ese ser perfecto que somos
y el segundo paso que viene de la mano
es
contagiemos a nuestro entorno
contagiamos a nuestro entorno de salud
como si fuésemos inmensos reflectores en
un estadio donde todo lo que topamos
iluminamos
qué bonito poder cambiar ese concepto en
lugar de andar por la vida intentando
brillar a pesar de que ese brillo pueda
ocasionar la oscuridad del de al lado
qué tal si nos planteamos iluminar
ser fuentes de luz
y ese es el 3er
paso de esta receta dejemos un legado
cómo quieres que te recuerden cuando ya
no estés aquí
la una opción
es como ese
funcionario amargado
antipático
egoísta
arrogante que nunca saludaba
y que siempre andaba
hablando mal de todo y de todos
la otra opción es que te recuerden como
ese colaborador simpático amable y
gentil solidario
generoso alegre ese que andaba por ahí
regando chispas de luz y siempre daba
gusto tenerlos cerca
como quiere como quieres tu ser
recordado cuando ya no estés
y yo compañeros en esta mañana
he venido a confesarles que desde lo más
profundo de mi corazón realmente quiero
cuando yo ya no esté el sistema en la
pantalla diga lo siguiente
confirmo y válido que la usuaria de esta
aplicación
verdaderamente no era un robot muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]